I wonder why I'm a bit tired. Fighting
torch compile all day.
Couple hours more of fighting torch
compile. I think that's going to be the
plan.
my favorite.
Well, it's got to get done one way or
the other, so
to because of pending uninvoked
backwards.
This seems screwy to me.
The [ __ ] is the point of having a grad
function like this if it's still going
to store the buffers in the same spot?
Huh?
The whole point is that we have to be
able to compile this thing.
Wait. Rad function
loss
roll out.
apparently this is the thing that breaks
it, right?
This still has gradients in it. So I
think that this is correct. I think I
just had it screwy before. I think I was
differentiating with respect to the
wrong thing before.
All right. Um,
sure.
Let's try that then.
Okay, that is something
we get to uh improve from here.
Cool.
Let me get this blanket off. It's too
hot.
I think we can figure something out
based on this, right?
I think it's pretty likely we can figure
something out based on this.
My chat broken.
I don't think so.
So you have the grad function
compile
and compute loss
the roll out
and then you compile the functional for
this is Good.
That's faster.
Well, that's no good.
Interesting.
All right. So, let's just do
low low end of um low low end is
priority support at like 10k, but we uh
you know we can scope substantially
larger jobs than that.
That's aimed at um that's aimed at
companies though. I do it for free for
universities
and I uh I teach like open source
contributors for free as well.
Mhm.
Exactly.
The main thing honestly that we get um
the main thing that most companies want
is uh custom simulators,
right? you know, they have a problem,
maybe they have some prototype RLM or
whatever, and they can't get anything to
work because stuff is super slow. We
write Sims that are a thousandx faster
than what's out there. We have training
code that's actually fast enough to keep
up and all these tools.
So, companies paid to just have like a
sim written in a way that's guaranteed
to work.
Okay. So, it's way slow with no compile.
About this
can break.
Okay.
What about this?
Firefly algorithm. What?
What is that?
That worse.
love your work. Recently came across
puffer grinded RL at work. I am
sincerely sorry about that. That library
has taken years off of many of our
lives, my own included during my PhD. I
feel your pain.
going to start deep dive into learning
more someone who's worked. Yeah. Go take
a look. Uh hang on, let me pause this.
Yeah. So, go take a quick look at um
Oops.
easiest thing is
I've got guides
on my X. If you just go to the articles
tab here,
this one's the one you're going to want.
takes you through making a little custom
envir.
If you do RL professionally, then uh the
first couple chunks of this will be
pretty easy
and you can build uh single agent,
multi- aent, whatever. Puffer doesn't
have like a ton of different algorithms
or stuff, but what we have is really
good and it's really really fast. It
should just crush our elab out of the
box.
Um oh yeah, then there's this fun
project.
I put this together for the community a
couple days ago so people can submit
puffers to the website.
Huh.
This is weird, right?
And there's nothing more to be gained by
doing this compile really.
There's no way that And you're saying
that that actually does something for a
confer
Can you think of a reason that M's act
like it builds
be found?
Did you register it? What?
I did change the build stuff yesterday.
Convert.
Um,
that's weird though.
I don't know.
Would not be found. Well, go look and
see if it actually put the file there,
right? Like if there's no binary there.
Oh.
Um,
do you have puffer lib? Like did you pip
install that puffer lib? Is it trying to
import from a different puffer li?
You probably just like did the rebuild
but didn't actually bind like the
current puffer lib.
Yeah, but did you pip install?
Wait, rather than puffer tank,
but if you have the source, did you pip
install- e the current repo? Because you
might have some other puffer lib like go
look at the path of uh of puffer liib
and see if it's importing from site
packages
any CNN's used in many areas. Yeah, we
use CNN's all over the place.
I've done that before. If you name a
file profile, you can mess up profiling
internals, which is fun.
Yeah, the separate nets thing has not
really been conclusive. There was a big
ablation that showed separate was better
for like one very specific robotics
thing.
I've seen it happen before, but it seems
kind of dumb to me.
I didn't even realize this test was
totally stupid.
Big difference.
Yeah, big difference.
Damn,
that's obnoxious.
um just the snakeet architecture from 20
was specifically designed because it's
like the only fast CNN I could come up
with.
It's designed for 11 by 11. Should be
easy enough to get it to work by 8 by8.
You have to do a little math.
Okay. Well, this is the thing that I
missed before, right? This is obnoxious
because this says that the compiled LSTM
cell is worse than this.
They're both better than I'm getting
now, though.
Oh, this is good. The batch size is kind
of good.
think having a PhD is bare minimum?
No,
not at all.
I have people that are contributing to
research and puffer that have barely
touched AI.
The only thing you can't get away from
is like putting in work.
Take a look at take a look at my guide,
right? I'm interested to see what you
like.
I don't know if you've done a high perf
sim before,
but
like RL with puffer is a totally
different field.
And that's not me over exaggerating.
Like it honestly just does not feel like
the same field.
What is your channel about like Puffer
Lib and RL like is beyond RL? So Puffer
Lib is my hyperfr library.
Um the project is just the project is
really more of a comprehensive effort to
just fix a ton of different things wrong
with the field. So it's not just like
make RL fast. There's also core
research, right? There's hyperparameter
stuff that we optimize. There's UI and
there's like visualization stuff I'm
working on now. Uh there's like high
performance simulation and simulation
techniques
and all of it goes into one very very
simple package. That's puffer in a
nutshell
and get into the industry.
Well, also know, right?
Like it depends, right? There are people
you're going to talk to who aren't going
to talk to you if you don't have the
paper credentials, but those people are
really stupid.
Puffer is the way to get engineers to
write code. Yeah. Yeah. Puffer is very
heavy.
Get started. Hairway trying to Yeah. And
then the thing is RLB is just never
going to be fast ever. The ray backend
is just wrong for um
uh for NSIM.
I don't know if you know how many steps
per second you're training, but our
x-axis on our graphs, right? Like we do
100 million steps in 30 seconds very
commonly.
millions of step per second training.
Like when RL is just a thousand times
faster, it doesn't feel like the same
field. And we have algorithmic
improvements to boot.
Are they CPU
opt? What are they? C We have CPUms that
run millions of steps per second per
core and then the entire training like
the entire training loop runs millions
of steps per second on one GPU.
You can get hund You can get like a
100,000 plus with a small networks
training on a CPU though if you really
want to do that for some reason.
All these agents are running in your
browser. This is not running server
side. You think I want to serve all
these agents?
Runs in your browser.
Type your library. Your library remains
so under the rad. It's not under the
radar. It's the fastest growing library
out there in RL. Look at this.
This is the growth on the project.
And my Twitter as well. I'm pretty sure
I now have um
I'm pretty sure I have the largest like
RL Twitter account as well given that I
pretty much just post about RL.
I pretty much just post RL. I don't
think there are any accounts that are as
like purely RL focused as mine that are
this big.
If you open the website on a Raspberry
Pi, that's on you. Okay.
I like I You're free to go optimize the
neural nets, but
Okay. So, there's the uncompiled
batched. That is a fair bit faster.
So this is what we could potentially get
with XLSTM.
Yeah, just they're fun to watch, right?
And the thing is like games are actually
meaningful in research. It's like common
criticism. Oh, RL's just used for
playing games. Like the people who say
this have about three brain cells uh
shared between them because like
The RL doesn't care if it's flying a
drone or playing a game. The RL doesn't
care if it's driving a car or playing a
game. We use games because they're
really easy to interpret when stuff goes
wrong. So, they're really good for
research
and they're pretty diverse in the
challenges that they pose.
I should still be able to get this to be
Oh, that's the inference,
Yeah, we're not doing quantization stuff
just so that we can run demos a little
better.
on your screen. What are you currently
building or testing?
Uh I this is currently like a mockup of
Puffer's training loop. It's got like a
very similar architecture and I'm
basically just abusing torch compile
until it spits out something that is at
least passibly performant.
There's some really, really aggressive
PF optimizations we need to make
Why compile so slow?
I guess it's running two tests.
You can also just grab the uh it's
literally in our docker.
So if you just do this,
it's a GPU container, so you'd need a
GPU for it. But if you just run this,
it'll include the uh I mean, I guess you
could also pull it out of here.
And there's the config file.
That's it. It's not rice.
Two plugins in a color scheme.
It's not like super tricked out. It's
pretty vanilla.
Weird.
The pile will take forever.
Well, for what, Jess? If you have a
general purpose model enhancement, maybe
I'm just listening to like random EDM
[ __ ]
to keep me awake.
Okay. See, this is what I thought. This
is weird as hell.
Oh, you dummy.
Wait, what?
Oh, dummy.
How did I do double quotes instead of
triple like that?
TensorFlow PyTorch.
There's no way you can't find tutorials
on PyTorch or TensorFlow. They're like
the two largest libraries out there.
There's about a million tutorials on
that
literally on the homepages of both of
them, I'm pretty sure as well.
Like usually I'm helpful to people, but
like come on.
I mean, PyTorch, they have like more
learning material than just about
anything else out there.
Because DQN's a bad algorithm.
Like what do you expect?
It's actually funny cuz like what we
have now is substantially better than
PO.
Um,
hang on.
So, here's the thing. the sample
efficiency wild goose chase literally
killed this field. Like that's the
entire reason that people got out of RL
in the first place. Um so I'm basically
at this point I'm sick of and tired of
even hearing it. Uh nobody bothered to
do any engineering at all.
Nobody needs to care about sample
efficiency. How many people in industry
do you think care about sample
efficiency when I say, "Hey, I can make
your sim really fast and then solve it
with RL." Zero. So if you just make the
Sims fast, you don't care about sample
efficiency. You actually care about
compute, right? You care about how much
compute it takes to solve your problem.
That's what actually costs money. And if
you can make your sim faster, that's
just as good as making the algorithm
faster.
And one of these two is actually
relatively straightforward to do. And
the other one is virtually impossible.
And it's not in comparison to how humans
learn. Humans have we have billions of
years of evolution baked in.
You know how we make our reward
functions. For our simple M's, we use
the first most obvious thing we think
of. For more complicated M's, we take
the first five most obvious things that
we think of and then we automatically
tune the weights with our hyperpar
tuning algorithm because we can do that.
Humans prove off Paul can work. What?
No.
Sleep at night.
I got another 45 minutes of this.
Maybe 30. I've been skipping out on too
much of my stretching lately.
I get a good hour of stretching in
tonight.
Not as awesome as just like lifting
heavy [ __ ] all day, but um
kind of important as it turns out.
Plus, I kind of want to lift to do a
little bit of accessory work as well.
I'll say I get like an extra three sets
of triceps in as well.
That'll be decent enough to have gotten
I got my six heavy sets in for the day.
And did three sets of five 355 deadlifts
and then three sets of I think I did
seven, six, and seven uh pull-ups with a
45 pound plate.
Torch compile is kind of insufferable
how long it takes.
Samsung, what
isotopic?
What the heck are these comments?
This is Athletic. It's a non-alcoholic
beer.
The only one that doesn't suck.
Samsung.
I don't know what a TRM is. If they have
a processor or something here, $100
shitty Samsung phone. I got this as a
temp cuz I broke my old one.
Okay, this is what we're looking for. So
according to this, we should be able to
hit like
say 15 20 million steps per second
training
with a smallish nets.
We should be able to throw together a
really sweet demo with this
This chunk is relatively easy to do.
I need I have Oh, that thing. It's kind
of It's kind of ironic that it's like
it's like tangentially sort of similar
to the first thing I ever did in
research. I did this like recurrent
highway hypernets thing.
I didn't look at the details of it, but
I don't know. sort of reminded me of
this.
Minerals.
The steak have minerals. I ate a lot of
that.
I want to start on this chunk today
because I'm going to mess it up if I do.
Let's just go add a couple things to
do everything a human human can do. It
would have to be as smart as a human is.
So solving the field
be a good description of the limitation.
Yeah. Is it six?
I see eight on YouTube, two on Twitch,
and I don't know how many on X.
It was up to like I think it was up to
like 16 earlier today.
Yeah, there you go. That's That's
autocast.
Uh that's when you have to get stuff
triaged
because like you can't answer all that
Yeah. And I'm going to go to bed pretty
soon as well. Well, not bed. I'm going
to go um do my stretching.
batch goes in B float.
Yeah, that's good.
So, you actually really don't lose much
by doing um B float here
and analyze or describe games but can't
play games. Yeah, they're stupid.
Okay.
So, this should be good. This at least
today we'll have gotten um this PF test
in
Yeah, it just I don't know, man. It's
better to just ignore the people
who don't actually want to like learn
things.
That's like embarrassingly bad
torch.
I wonder if he was um
I wonder if can we try like the trace
jet instead of compile?
Is that easy to do for evaluate?
It's kind of not right.
Can you jet trace a model?
Right.
Uh when I'm unf when I have dealing with
stuff I'm completely unfamiliar with.
And then the most common one is this. I
have a really dumb model that's oneline
autocomplete,
which like just makes you type fast. I
like this one.
Basically just removes typing speed from
consideration.
Oh, cuz you dummy. Why? Why do I have
train on like this? This is supposed to
be gone. Okay, hang on.
Okay. So, this is what we get out of
torch at the end of the day, right?
So we have 3.8 3.4 and 29 like high 20s.
We have high threes high 20s. Yeah.
Okay. And then Jax gives us
lower train, higher evalu.
Okay.
So, Python ends up being uh torch ends
up being a little bit better.
And then this
minus one for Jax for killing my stream
for a second there.
So even just with reduce overhead,
we're already matching jacks.
I'm not going to give you that
information, but yeah, there's some
people I would think of.
Um,
could I not just write the damn code the
exact same way?
So, basically, this is Yeah, it's the
same code.
I'd have to write the optimizer this
way, but other than that, it's fine.
Mega pain in the ass.
Really a mega pain in the ass.
The thing that's obnoxious here is this
needs to get duped over seeds, right?
So guys, I guess let me tell you what's
going through my head at the moment,
right? Um,
I played around with a ton a ton of
different things here, okay?
And like we made some decent progress.
So even with a version of stuff that
compiles
um here, let's just do it this way.
So with a version that compiles like
relatively fast,
like this is like a relatively friendly
usable version.
Yeah. So we get like quite a speed up
here. You see?
So
presumably I'm going to be able to speed
this up several fold over what puffer is
now. And this is also BF16.
So like presumably
I can get some good speed up.
But
this is still using
a 20th of the GPU.
I'm trying to think basically like
do we want to cue multiple jobs on the
same GPU at the same time?
M information please.
Uh I think Helix does sort of right.
I don't know that area.
I have a feeling the Jack's eager mode
is super slow, right? Because Jax is
just not meant for eager.
I wonder if we can get optimal flops uh
out of packing then.
That's an interesting idea, right?
10 years.
Depends how many stupid comments I have
to answer on the internet.
It's okay. I'll make sure that if I lose
all my hair from the stream, I'm still
jacked enough to pull the look off.
Speaking of which,
I gotta go. Um,
I got to go do my stretching and call a
night. So, let me finish my thought here
though. Um,
what we have discovered from today. So,
one, we are now absolutely certain that
Jax is not magically faster than torch.
Okay. The thing that Jax is nice for is
that it's you don't have to fight its
compilation anywhere near as much.
That's the only thing. Uh you have to
write all your code completely
different,
but you don't have to fight the thing so
much,
which is kind of nice. Kind of okay. I
don't know.
Torch is still
the preferred library. I'd say you can
also get more out of Torch. Um, once you
have compile, you can get more out of
Torch with Tuning, but the freaking
compile settings for that take forever.
The only other thing that remains to be
seen here. So
I want to investigate packing.
Basically
maybe we should just look at jobs in
terms of
blops instead of wall clock, right?
Because maybe
maybe we can essentially have multiple
jobs uh on the same GPU
for small nets
and we can just always get everything up
to uh like near perfect flop util or
whatever and then we can count stuff in
terms of flops
which would be super nice.
I think that's probably what we're going
to investigate. If I have time to do
tomorrow,
that's what we will investigate.
cuz this number is not good or
satisfying. Now the thing that is good
okay
like this number implies that we should
with basic compilation be able to get at
least 10 mil step per second training.
So we should be able to make puffer two
to three times faster than it is now
which is kind of awesome. But then the
thing is this is like oneif of the speed
that you can get out of your GPU.
So like I want 100 million step per
second training
and we should be able to get 100 million
step per second training.
I'm going to have to think about it
though. Now, I guess one thing we can
do,
I did figure out the the functional
thing that I figured out was the unlock
that lets us uh compile pretty much
whatever we like.
So, we can probably do Jack style VM
maps with that. We'll see.
And then that would if we did that it
would make it really easy essentially to
uh to use multiple backends.
I think that might be the way to go is
that we have normal torch modules. You
have the class interface and then you
just have the functional call on it.
I think that's probably the way to go.
We made some good progress either way
today. We made some good progress. This
shit's hard, you know, like when you
have to deal with stuff like this, it's
a pain in the ass. Um, if you're
interested in my work, just give the X a
follow. Give the GitHub a star. Feed the
puffer. Uh, there's going to be more. I
think we probably have a couple PRs to
only fish, right?
yeah, here's a nice little PR to the
puffer. So we have another fish to
emerge in tomorrow as well, which will
be funny.